j'arrive toujours joué par nicholas
atteindre moi je crois qu'ils sont
perdus
alors qu'est-ce que ça c'est magique
apprenait que tel appareil bonsoir lui
au fond c'est toi maman tu viens nous
arrivons nous voilà et chez vous attend
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants bonsoir oui nous
avons eu quelques petits ennuis notre
gouverneur ne marche plus
impossible de le faire tourner il est si
lourd que nous avons de la peine à
avancer
tu ferais bien de le vérifier nounours
je m'en occupe pas trop ma lampe de
poche ou la guitare ça a l'air sérieux
[Musique]
que loup tient nounours ton et chaîne
hopla me reçut mon petit pas trop propre
propre propre propre aux pros au bout a
très vite nounours mais qu'est ce que
t'as parts notre gouvernail et deux mois
les enfants ce qui le loue et didot
s'est on va faire un gouvernail notre
gouverneur sert à diriger notre nuage
comme un bateau et je lui ai apporté ici
pour le réparer car il ne marche pas
bien j'en ai besoin
voyons mais mais
mais c'est un nid d'oiseau avec deux
heures de danse est ce qu un os qu il
est jeune on va le poser devant la
fenêtre sur une chaise pour que les
parts on le retrouve et reviennent dans
leurs nuits oui mais on laissera la
fenêtre au maire très bonne idée
je le pose là il est bien
n'y touchez pas surtout allez vous
coucher les enfants
moi je m'occupe du gouverneur tu
viendras nous dire bonsoir les bien sûr
les petits à vous pas trop attaché le
bien allez-y vous pouvez leur montée je
m'en occupe pas tranquille d'ours
[Musique]
elle annonce vient me voilà voilà
bonne nuit les petits buy-ins enough là
je teins la lumière à demain à touba
bonne nuit nicolas fait pour rêves tu
apprenais du des enfants n'oubliez pas
de faire votre toilette de bien vous
laver les dents
embrassez vos parents et allez vite vous
coucher on y va patron le gouvernail
d'être en place tout est en ordre mon
cher nounours en route allons vite nous
coucher nous aussi 2 adobe
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]